Pues nos piden factorizar
"t" cuadrada más 8t más 15,
y antes quiero ver qué es lo que pasa
cuando nosotros multiplicamos
2 binomios de la forma
"t" más "a" por "t" más "b"
y es que es justo de esta manera,
como voy a querer
factorizar a este trinomio
de la forma
"t" más "a" por "t" más "b",
y bueno que nos sale  de multiplicar
"t" mas "a" por "t" más "b",
pues es "t" por "t" me quedaría "t" cuadrada
después sería "t" por "b"
sería "bt"
y después sería
"a" por "t" lo cual me daría "at"
y después al último,
sería "a" por "b"
y bueno, si te das cuenta
aquí abajo podemos factorizar una "t"
tenemos "t" cuadrada
más bt, más at, más "ab"
"bt" más "at"
podemos factorizar de aquí una "t"
¿y qué me quedaría?
"t" cuadrada más "a" más "b",
todo esto en paréntesis,
que multiplica "t",
"t" por "a" es "at",
"t" por "b" es "bt"
más "ab" y bueno,
esto es justo lo que yo quiero ver aquí en este vídeo.
Si te das cuenta lo que voy a buscar es que aquí,
"t" cuadrada tenga un 1,
aquí "t" cuadrada tiene un 1,
por lo tanto vamos bien,
y después nos podemos fijar en quién
es el número que está al lado de la "t",
este número que es 8 tiene que ser "a" más "b",
tiene que ser la suma de los 2 números
y el término libre,
el término que no tiene nada que ver con "t"
es decir,
el 15 que tengo aquí,
tiene que ser el producto de estos 2 números,
y es más,
lo podemos ver
hasta en un caso mucho más general,
que tal si en lugar de "t" le ponemos "x"
como siempre lo manejan.
Si nosotros tenemos en la forma Ç¿No sé?
"x" cuadrada, vamos a ponerlo aquí,
"x" cuadrada más "bx" más "c",
y el coeficiente que está lado
de la "x" cuadrada es 1,
entonces buscaríamos 2 números
que sumados me den "b",
y que multiplicados me den "c"
esto de manera general,
aquí sumados me tienen que dar 8
y multiplicados me tienen que dar 15,
¿Y quiénes son estos números?
Bueno, 15 se puede factorizar en 15 y 1,
en 5 y 3.
¡Espera! Creo que 5 y 3
me parece una buena opción,
5 más 3 es 8 y
5 por 3 es 15.
Fíjate bien, lo voy a poner aquí,
si yo tengo 5 y 3,
3 por 5 es 15
y 3 más 5 es 8
perfecto,  entonces parece ser que ya encontré
mis términos que estoy buscando,
mis números que estoy buscando.
Entonces ahora me voy a ir de regreso,
si es cierto esto que acabo de decir,
entonces, esto se puede ver
de la siguiente manera.
Lo voy a escribir así,
voy a poner "t" cuadrada,
después tengo "bt"
pero en este caso "v" a a ser uno de los
dos numeritos que acaba de encontrar, entonces,
voy a suponer que es 3
entonces me queda "t" cuadrada...
y ahora es aquí donde me voy a fijar,
en los números que acabo de encontrar, 3 y 5,
3 y 5 me suman 8t,
por lo tanto, me va a quedar más 3 veces "t",
más 3 veces "t" más 5 veces "t",
para que me den 8t.
Fíjate que lo que estoy haciendo
es irme de atrás hacia adelante.
Ahora voy de abajo,
hacia arriba,
tengo "t" cuadrada
más 3t más 5t más 15,
y bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer
es factorizar por agrupación.
Me voy a fijar
en los primeros dos términos
y me voy a fijar también en mis segundos dos términos
para factorizar esta expresión,
y "t" cuadrada más 3t
es lo mismo que,
voy a factorizar una "t"
es lo más que se puede reducir,
y me va a quedar,
"t" que multiplica a "t" más 3
y después de 5t más 15
me queda que mi factor común es 5,
5 que multiplica a su vez
a "t" más 3
5 por "t" es 5t  y 5 por 3 es 15,
entonces hasta aquí vamos bien.
A continuación lo que quiero que te des cuenta,
es que aquí tenemos "t" más 3 y "t" más 3
multiplicando tanto a "t"  como a 5,
por lo tanto,
lo voy a sacar como si fuera un factor común,
y entonces me va a quedar,
"t" mas 3 que multiplica a "t" más 5,
déjame poner un más que no parezca tanto "t",
un más un poco más estructurado,
y me queda "t" más 5
y date cuenta que
"t" más 3 por "t" es "t" por "t" más 3
y "t" más 3 por...
es 5 por "t" más 3
¿y qué crees?
ya encontré la factorización
de "t" cuadrada
más 8 "t" más 15,
que es "t" más 3 por "t" más 5
y bueno, no forzosamente
se tiene que hacer todo este procedimiento.
Hay veces que solamente fijándote
en esto que tenemos aquí arriba,
es decir, solamente buscando 2 números
que sumados te den 8 y multiplicados te den 15,
podemos encontrar el resultado.